the British soldier
all around the globe you'll find him
from Gibraltar to Hong Kong
everywhere he stands against the
threatening years
staunch symbol of our common Will to
order
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
the British Empire
the largest Empire the world has ever
known
for over 300 years Britain ruled its
Army is conquered and its Bankers
proclaimed the might of its currency
but one day it all began to fall apart
one by one countries declared their
independence from Britain and no amount
of force could reverse the tide
as British Elites saw their wealth
Privileges and Empire disintegrate they
began to search for a new role in a
changing world and they found one in
finance
[Music]
this is a film about how Britain
transformed from a colonial power to a
modern Financial power and how this
transformation has shaped the world we
live in
[Music]
the days of the British Empire the city
of London was the world's biggest Global
Financial Center
the city of London was the kind of
beating Financial heart of the British
Empire the historians Kane and Hopkins
call it the governor of the Imperial
engine all these countries in the Empire
used to use the Sterling currency and
the city of London was kind of the
financier of this so not just inside the
Sterling Zone but outside the Sterling
Zone as well as Britain's Empire
declined so too did the city of London
one British army truck is bombed killing
two soldiers and wounding twelve as
rioting becomes daily more widespread on
Cyprus young people of high school age
take an increasing part in the violence
you here a group of girls are being
dispersed after a rock throwing battle
with British military police
British commercial interests across the
globe were under threat
in 1956 Egypt nationalized the Suez
Canal
crisis arises as president Nasser of
Egypt tells a wildly Turing crowd in
Alexandria
that Egypt has seized the
internationally owned Suez Canal
France and Britain issue a 12-hour
ultimatum within hours of its
exploration Britain's warplanes are
bringing their way to Egypt and its
bombers attacked five key cities
including Cairo
the United States was opposed to The
Invasion and put pressure on Britain and
France to withdraw their troops
there will be no United States
involvement in these present hostilities
it is our hope and intent this matter
will be brought before the United
Nations General Assembly there the
opinion of the world can be brought to
bear in our quest for a just end to this
tormenting problem
Britain was humiliated
the Suez Crisis signified the end of
Britain's role as one of the world's
major powers
[Music]
following the crisis there was a run on
the Sterling on the UK pound
some people suspect that the American
government was encouraging this round on
the UK pound
as financiers withdrew their money from
Britain the value of the pound decreased
to protect the value of the pound
Britain limited the bank's overseas
Lending
they were not able
to invest abroad and obviously they were
unhappy and we don't know exactly the
context but it's very clear that the
banks or their representative made a
representation to the bank of England
which in itself was dominated by
representative from the banking industry
it seems that they have reached an
agreement
which was never written that if the
banks
intermediated between two non-residents
in a foreign currency in that case
dollar that this particular
intermediation this particular deal will
not be considered by the bank of England
under its own jurisdiction
Banks began to create a market for
dollars in London called the London euro
dollar market
to differentiate these Euro Market
activities from their domestic banking
activities Banks kept two sets of
accounts
the bank of England the UK regulator
declared that the London Euro market
accounts were not in London they were
elsewhere and therefore it had no
responsibility for regulating them
it's about providing a legal space in
which you pretend activity is taking
place and the importance of that is that
you pretend it's not taking place
in the economy where it really is taking
place so you're taking activity from the
place where it's regulated and taxed and
pretending that it's happening elsewhere
now where it doesn't really matter it's
just elsewhere
when American Banks realized that London
offered the ability to avoid U.S
regulations they moved their
International operations to the city
[Music]
around the same time as American Banks
were moving their International
operations to London
another new kind of financial space
began to emerge far away from London in
Britain's overseas jurisdictions the
last remnants of Empire
back in the 60s the Cayman Islands was a
complete Backwater the stories go that
mosquitoes were so thick in the air
sometimes they're enough to suffocate
cows that's a legend that you hear about
the Cayman Islands I don't know how true
it was but it was there was nothing
happening that
accountants and lawyers from London
arrived in the Cayman Islands and other
British dependencies and began to draft
a set of financial secrecy laws and
regulations
because these jurisdictions main selling
point for secrecy they were called
secrecy jurisdictions
[Music]
what the Cayman Islands was doing was
straightforwardly illegal activity drugs
money was coming in in huge quantities
um tax evasion whatever whatever you
wanted you could have it
the bank of England was observing the
developments from London and noted in a
report marked secret dated 11th of April
1969.
we need to be quite sure that the
possible proliferation of trust
companies Banks Etc which in most cases
would be no more than brass plates
manipulating assets outside the islands
does not get out of hand
there is of course no objection to their
providing bolt holes for non-residents
but we need to be sure that in so doing
opportunities are not created for the
transfer of UK Capital to the
non-sterling area outside UK rules
[Music]
these small territories the last
remnants of the British Empire which are
still overseas territories today they
are still the last remnants of the
British Empire
um there are 14 of these overseas
territories seven of them are bona fide
a tax Havens including the Cayman
Islands Bermuda the British Virgin
Islands some of the biggest tax Havens
in the world today are still British
[Music]
with access to large amounts of offshore
money the Euro Market grew rapidly
by 1980 it had reached 500 billion
dollars
by 1988 4.8 trillion dollars and by 1997
nearly 90 of all International loans
were made through this Market
the British Empire had sunk leaving
hardly a trace behind
but the city of London adapted and
survived
the city of London London's financial
district is a peculiar place
it has been called a city within a city
a state within a state
it is run by an organization called the
city of London Corporation
a private company that performs all the
functions of a local council with a
private police force and private courts
those of you who aren't from the UK some
of you even who are might not be aware
just how weird a thing the little city
of London is within the big city the big
London the city of London is a separate
entity to The Wider London and it has
its own heads the Lord mayor he's
distinct from the mayor who runs the
rest of London
every November the city stages the Lord
mayor's show the world's oldest Civic
procession
[Music]
the city of London has long had this
curious legal status because
um back in 1066 when William the
Conqueror came over the city was one of
the only portions of England that he
failed to conquer and he struck a deal
with the city in 1067 that allowed them
to continue functioning
to this day the city of London is exempt
from numerous laws that govern the rest
of Britain
its political system derives from the
Middle Ages the city's electorate is
dominated not by its residents but by
the private businesses operating within
the city
it's Lord mayor is selected by the heads
of medieval guilds
they have a representative in the House
of Commons called the remembrancer apart
from the clerks of the court of the
class of Commons he's the only unelected
person there all other lobbyists have to
stop you know in the lobby they're not
allowed past the lobby the city of
London has a permanent representative in
the House of Commons whose role is to
report back to the city of London
Corporation and to Lobby Parliament on
behalf of the city
the cooperation of London clearly
it's a uniquely unique and interesting
phenomenon that should have attracted
many political scientists political
economies and economists
but I don't know if anyone who has
studied systematically the cooperation
in London and its impact
policy
or economic policy
so we can only surmise
some people
uh assume or summarize that the
cooperation of London is extremely
powerful and is able in one way or
another to shape
British policy particularly within
Financial methods clementley the Prime
Minister after the second world war
um had had something to say about the
Steve London Corporation he did yeah so
over and over again we have seen that
there is in this country another power
than that which has its seat at
Westminster the city of London a
convenient term for a collection of
financial interests is able to assert
itself against the government of the
country those who control money can
pursue a policy at home and abroad
contrary to that which has been decided
by the people
at the heart of the city of London
stands the bank of England
the bank of England is not just a
central bank it is also a financial
regulator
at the demise of Empire the bank of
England used this regulatory authority
to help attract the world's Banks to
London
in 1972 the bank of England issued a
license to the bank of credit and
commerce International which set up its
head office in London
within 10 years BCCI grew into the
seventh largest bank in the world
Ten Years Later
BCCI was bankrupt
the deputy director of the CIA Richard
Kerr said late today that the CIA did
use BCCI to support CIA activities
overseas
but BCCI had not just collaborated with
the world's intelligence services
it had also engaged in extensive
financial fraud money laundering and
terrorist financing
constituted International Global crime
crime of a level that boggles the Mind
BCCI was financing terrorism the bank of
England knew it says the report but
instead of supervising it properly it
tried to prevent the bank's collapse I
am saying very directly that the bank of
England had sufficient information in
front of it to close BCCI 15 months
earlier than it did millions of
depositors were heard in that process
numerous whistleblowers from BCCI had
contacted the bank of England
yet the bank of England did nothing
the bank of England had plenty of time
to intervene and investigate but it did
not do so because the tradition at that
time would still survives is that a
while actually you know you have to just
kind of send hints and talk over lunch
tables with the chaps regulating other
chaps and all would be well
Robin Lee Pemberton the governor of the
bank of England at the time of the
collapse of BCCI commented the present
system of supervision has served the
community well
if we close down a bank every time he
found an incidence of fraud you would
have rather fewer Banks than we do at
the moment
London was a place for banks to engage
in business that was not allowed
elsewhere
where senior Bankers did not have to
worry about the consequences of their
actions
this is one of the reasons why today
there are more banks in London than in
any other Financial Center
in Britain nobody goes to jail no
Bankers go to jail they generally don't
they are a protected species and that is
part of the offshore business model of
the UK is to say we will protect you we
will bring your money here we will look
after you we're not going to put you in
prison we'll let you do what you want
light touch regulation was one way of
attracting business to London another
was secrecy
from the 1960s onwards city of London
institutions began to establish offshore
branches in former outposts of the
British Empire their aim was to create
offshore centers with strong secrecy
legislation in order to attract capital
from across the globe
Swiss banking Secrets is the most famous
the most well-known you know put the
money at Swiss bank and they won't they
promised not to tell anybody and that's
one kind of secrecy but another kind of
secrecy which is very British is the
trust and the trust is a very slippery
complicated and devious mechanism
trusts emerge the legend has it from the
time of the Crusades when the knights
would go from fighting foreign lands and
they would leave their Assets in the
care of trusted stewards what trusts do
ultimately is they play with the concept
of ownership ownership is not such a
simple thing so the settler the knight
in this case would hand over the assets
to
someone who these days would be called a
trustee it's often a lawyer legally you
are separated from those assets they're
not yours anymore there's a barrier
you can't be taxed on them you can't be
nobody's going to find anything about
your connection to these assets
in Britain's offshore jurisdictions no
qualifications are necessary to be a
trustee
anyone can set up a trust and act as a
trustee
there is no registry of trusts
there are no bodies to certify that a
trust has been set up
the only persons who know about the
creation of this agreement are the
trustee and the settler there's no
obligation to register it there is no
financial reporting obligation of trusts
they're not required to put annual
statements onto account anywhere so
actually trusts are to all intents and
purposes invisible Arrangements
economist John Christensen was an
economic advisor to the secrecy
jurisdiction of Jersey for 10 years
we're not talking about a few million
we're talking now about trillions
trillions of dollars of capital which
apparently belonged to nobody
tax purposes and for other purposes they
belong to nobody everything works of
Arts gold bullion horse racehorses cars
real estate not just Financial assets
but a whole load of non-financial assets
belong to these trusts
sitting there belonging to nobody
now think that one's through which we
are talking about maybe as much as 50
trillion dollars of assets sitting
offshore Behind These instruments well
the Cayman Islands are among several
British overseas territories who have
signed a new information exchange
agreement with Britain and the rest of
Europe to tackle tax evasion the
countries are now required to
automatically provide details of the
ownership of bank accounts and how
they're used Cayman became the first
signatory last week it's important that
the Cayman Islands should be recognized
as the first overseas territory to sign
such an agreement with the United
Kingdom
and I think this importantly reflects
the constructive approach that the
Cayman Islands has taken in delivering
our shared objective of rooting out tax
evasion
[Music]
the trust lies at the core of the
British secrecy model they don't use
banking secrecy the Swiss used banking
secrecy the British of course are only
too willing to kill a banking secrecy
because they will then capture a larger
market share that's why the Brits are
doing this
[Music]
trusts are the basic building block of
anglo-saxon secrecy and they form the
basis from which complex offshore
structures are created
every secrecy jurisdiction offers a
specific set of services from trusts to
Shell companies to secret bank accounts
and nominee directors
the combination of these Services into
complex structures spanning multiple
jurisdictions enables the creation of
secrecy structures that are almost
impossible to penetrate
an offshore structure will often have a
trust kind of sitting at the top of it
the trust will be here managing the
assets kind of controlling the assets
underneath it the trust will own some
shell companies each one might be in a
different joystick so you might have a
trust in one jurisdiction whose trustees
are somewhere else whose beneficiaries
are somewhere else which owns offshore
companies somewhere else each of these
companies might then own assets so that
they might own you know a bank account a
racehorse a yacht a painting a portfolio
of shares or whatever
there are numerous variations of trusts
and offshore secrecy structures
there are offshore lawyers whose work
entails the creation of ever more
complex and obscure structures
the aim of these structures is to hide
the identity of the owners of offshore
assets and allow offshore wealth to be
recycled back into Global markets
but looking on the amount of money
being administrated from
tax Heavens you see that it is a curb
going like this and all the Talking we
have been doing along with other
wonderful people fighting against tank
Silence has not changed anything you
know it is the world where you say go on
talking and go on talking you're
interesting me and I'm going on doing
what I want to do we know everything
today because we have had the Panama
papers we have seen it
and we are not able to act upon it and
we are not able to act upon it because
this system is really protecting
few people that are having benefit from
it and these are in percentage very few
people but they are powerful
and I see in the Panama committee that
I'm sitting in the only thing that could
change this is to have a public
accessible register of the beneficial
ownership of trusts and of all kinds of
companies it is easy
the Panama papers are a collection of
leaks from the offshore Law Firm mossack
vonseca
mosac Fonseca is the fourth largest
offshore Law Firm
the other nine of the 10 largest
offshore law firms are registered in
British overseas jurisdictions
when countries complain to Britain about
the activities run out of its offshore
Havens
Britain claims that these places are
independent and that there is nothing it
can do I've heard time and time again
from officials in Berlin and in Paris
and in Washington and in other countries
that they've been told by the British
government
yes they're well aware of what's going
on in Jersey and they think it's very
unfortunate but they don't have the
powers to intervene well that's a
straightforward lie
they do have the powers to intervene
they just choose not to
Britain plays this kind of game of
um pretending when it suits them to
pretend that these places are
independent at the end of the day
Britain appoints the governor appoints
lots of senior people in these places
they're responsible for foreign
relations and defense and also they can
veto their legislation as well so
Britain has a massive degree of control
basically it is controlling these places
allowing them a little bit of political
space
during his time as economic adviser to
Jersey John Christensen frequently
traveled to London for talks with
various British government departments
as economic advisor I had a lot of
contact with different departments
um
traditionally UK governments have tried
not to interfere in the domestic affairs
of places like Jersey so it happens in a
more subtle sort of way you kind of go
and talk to someone either the home
office or the treasury and they'd say
well not actually particularly keen on
this piece of legislation it might be a
good idea if you didn't go down that
route and over a cup of tea that's quite
a strong signal that's a signal go back
to the island and say they don't want
you to do this
[Music]
the British government prefers not to
interfere overtly
instead it communicates its desires
through informal discussions
there is no paper trail or official
statement discussions take place behind
closed doors
the relationship that these places have
with London is is very much about the
British establishment and people
understanding each other I mean anybody
who knows who is British or knows a
British British people knows that
communication between us is often very
subtle and
you have to kind of
know the codes when people say stuff I
mean a lot of irony involved and um a
lot of um kind of codified language the
British establishment that um people
kind of understand how it works and I
think that is very much the case with
the British relationship with the tax
Havens I think there's a lot of
understanding of what we can and can't
do without anyone having to actually
spell it out
by keeping its power hidden Britain is
able to claim that these jurisdictions
are politically autonomous
Independence for cayman is not on
government's agenda that's the message
being sent to the UN special committee
on decolonization attorney Steve mcfeel
will be representing government at the
U.N meeting the committee was set up to
help colonies around the world on the
road to Independence but Mr McBeal says
he'll be making it clear that Cayman is
not ready for that transition
and that message is that the premier Ms
cabinet his party has no mandate from
the people of the Cayman Islands to seek
Independence that is the message that I
will be carrying
when the Bahamas declared independence
from Britain in 1967
the offshore Bankers relocated to the
Cayman Islands and continued their
business from there
it was the British connection that
reassured bankers and their clients that
their money was safe
this British Bedrock that is what has
allowed these places to become so
trusted by the financial services
industry in an offshore finance and all
these people
in reality much of the wealth
administered in Britain's offshore
Havens is controlled from London
the city of London by and large likes to
do its really dirty work outside London
they might heaven forbid be a regulator
that actually takes the job seriously
and starts to prosecute them for fraud
in London so better to do the forwards
offshore in Gibraltar or Jersey
where there's much less risk than a
serious prosecution will ever happen
deals are often discussed and concluded
in London but then registered offshore
for tax transparency and Regulatory
purposes
what they allow the city to do is to get
involved in dirty business
but then when the Scandal hits
to say Well they're kind of independent
there's nothing we can do about those
places that's that's not us that's
that's tax Haven activity and we're the
city you know we're we're not involved
in that kind of stuff so it's an
incredibly kind of convenient
relationship
the city of London
has shaped the the way in which Jersey
Guernsey and the British overseas
territories have developed as tax Havens
I see these places at the Frankensteins
created by by the city of London
today the UK is the world's largest
provider of International Financial
Services the UK has an almost unique
role in global finance and if you look
at data
the kind of data that we've constructed
in the financial secrecy index you can
see the relative shares of each country
in the global provision of financial
services exports that's Financial
Services to non-residents
now there are two big centers and
everything else is quite small in
comparison
the two large centers are the United
States with around 19 of the global
market and the United Kingdom and its
offshore jurisdictions which have around
25 of the global market
and if you add to that
other jurisdictions
ex-colonies but recently dependent
fairly recently by which I mean Hong
Kong
Singapore maybe even Dubai and Bahrain
and Cyprus
then you reach the figure of nearly 40
percent
and I think that figure represents
better
the position of London in the Global
Financial Market
and the soldiers left that the
administrators left all the colonies but
they still kept a significant degree of
control over the financial flows from
these former
um the former parts of Empire and the
rest of the world so you could describe
it as a Second Empire
Britain's Second Empire sort of hidden
Financial Empire spanning large parts of
the globe
at the time of the British Empire the
city of London was the world's largest
Global Financial Center
not only Britain's colonies but also
independent countries did their banking
in London and used the Empire's currency
for trade and financing
as the Empire declined so too did the
city of London
the establishment of the London Euro
Market enabled city of London Banks to
continue to exploit their Empire Era
networks and expertise and the creation
of secrecy jurisdictions gave Banks
access to large amounts of cheap money
International Banks from across the
globe set up branches in London and
Britain's offshore jurisdictions in
order to take advantage of this new
system
this system has taken the place of the
occupation
I mean up till 62 for France I don't
know for England but about the same time
England were physically present in India
for instance or in in other colonies
and when you look at the money flows
through the tax heavens
they are increasing when we withdraw
from the colonies
we are still plundering developing
countries as former Colonial covers
wealthy individuals organized crime and
corporations shifted their wealth
offshore in exchange for secrecy and no
tax
and as countries around the world began
to deregulate and open their economies
it became ever easier to do so
today as much as half of all Global
offshore wealth may be hidden in
Britain's secrecy jurisdictions
one of the losers is Africa whose flight
Capital flows mostly into the modern
British spider's web
I think it's no coincidence that
Britain's offshore
Empire
and most more or less at the same time
as the collapse of the formal Empire we
tend to think of Africa as being a huge
net debtor to the rest of the world
but that was the extent of their debts
at the end of 2008 177 billion
the debt of sub-Saharan African nations
stood at 177 billion dollars in 2008.
yet the wealth these countries Elites
had moved offshore between 1970 and 2008
is estimated at 944 billion dollars
over five times their foreign debt
944 billion dollars
do the maths far from being a net debtor
Africa sub-Saharan Africa is a net
credited to the rest of the world
as capital moved offshore African
nations borrowed money from
International Banks at high interest
over time these debts became so great
that they may never be repaid
secrecy jurisdictions were starving
developing nations of their wealth and
their tax revenues
for a long time a lot of developing
countries including recently Ecuador
have been trying to set up a un tax body
which is of a higher value than what is
currently there which is the U.N tax
committee and every time this has
happened it has gotten blocked during
the financing for development process in
Addis Ababa last year uh I think it was
the UK and the US that blocked attempts
again to set up this world tax
organization so why would they not want
to have Democratic decision-making in
global decisions on how tax gets
collected across borders I don't
understand this as long as we have
cross-border activity that involves both
criminal and legal activity as long as
we're unable to separate the two this is
going to continue to be a problem
Western Nations block attempts to
provide greater transparency of
International Financial flows and the
implementation of global standards for
the collection of tax across borders
whilst Elites in developing nations use
offshore centers to hide their wealth
offshore
the oil from Gabon has not benefited
people in Gabon
and this is true for the copper in
Zambia for the for the
going in the Mozambique or in Mali they
have benefited the
company that to extract it and they are
shareholders
it has benefited the corrupt Elite in
the country in developing countries
the offshore system of tax Havens has
facilitated the Looting of these
countries by their Elites
it has enabled them to steal the money
and keep it safe somewhere else illicit
Financial flows because the anonymity
that drives them creates incentives for
people in positions of power to be
corrupt this is why there's a group of
countries where development progress is
so difficult it's that the incentives of
individuals and the ability to pursue
them through all the mechanisms that
underpin initiative lose
outweigh the type of mechanisms that in
that lead you to a powerful
representative effective state that can
start to deliver development
foreign
[Music]
developing countries lose over a
trillion dollars every year in capital
flight and tax evasion
most of this wealth flows into large
Western Nations like the United States
and Britain and enables their currencies
to stay strong whilst developing nations
currencies remain weak
but illicit flows into Western Nations
also had another unexpected side effect
the economies of the United States and
Britain began to financialize
the origins of this financialization or
de-industrialization go back to the
1960s
anti-war demonstrators protest U.S
involvement in the Vietnam War in Mass
marches rallies and demonstrations
President Johnson meanwhile let it be
known that the FBI is closely watching
all anti-war activity
in the 1960s U.S Economist Michael
Hudson was working at Chase Manhattan
Bank on Wall Street as Chase's balance
of payments Economist during the 1960s
the United States uh balanced a payments
deficit was entirely a result of foreign
military expenditures dollars were
flowing out of the United States as a
result of the cost of the Vietnam War
the United States attempted to prevent
the dollars flowing to Vietnam from
being deposited in foreign Banks
the government asked Chase to set up a
branch in Saigon during the Vietnam war
and as you can imagine it didn't have
Windows it was sort of a fortress it
lost money but the government went to
chase because it said if you don't get
this uh money that's being thrown off by
the military in Vietnam then it's going
to go into French banks it'll get to
General to go and you know what he's
going to do every month he's going to
cash it in for gold that's what the
United States is trying to stop
the U.S was not successful in stopping
the outflow of money so it began to
hatch a different plan
in 1967 Michael Hudson was handed a memo
by a former State Department employee in
1967 I was given by a former State
Department employee in the elevator at
Chase Manhattan a memo from the state
department
urging the trace Manhattan would take
the lead in helping the United States
become the Switzerland of the world
meaning the flight Capital the state
department through Chase asked me to
estimate how much money do you think is
available if America were to become the
new Switzerland and how do we do it the
plan was to organize Offshore Banking
centers in the Caribbean and elsewhere
and the hot money wouldn't come directly
into Chase because that wouldn't be uh
nice and very legal what happened was
that the Latin American criminals other
criminals drug dealers all sorts of
organized crime would put their money in
the offshore Caribbean in Banks and
these offshore Banks would then deposit
the inflow in the head office
by moving offshore dollars back into the
United States the U.S was able to stop
the outflow of dollars and support the
value of its currency
every country looks towards foreign
exchange rate and uh the foreign
exchange rate is not only imports and
exports its capital movements and if you
look at the international monetary funds
monthly International financial
statistics you have sort of a steady
balance of trade a steady immigrants
remittances what goes up and down are
called errors and omissions what the
United Nations and the IMF call errors
and omissions are flight Capital it's
the the reason that it's omitted is they
don't like to really look at this in the
1930s Roy Ovid Hall Economist for the
U.S Commerce Department wanted to
include a criminal a movements in the
balance of payment statistics and
Congress got very upset I I was told in
Washington the cut the argument was
we're a Christian country we don't want
to report crime it's just don't look at
it and they they forbid him to include
uh criminal money in the balance of
payments I guess now you call it errors
and omissions you don't call it criminal
inflow and outflow
1960s
is
Britain was faced with a similar dilemma
as the United States
money was flowing out and this decreased
the value of the pound
Britain realized that it too could
support the value of its currency by
opening its domestic markets to the
trillions of dollars passing through its
offshore Havens
but just as in the United States this
had an unexpected side effect the
British Banks today just as in the 19th
century don't put their money into
British manufacturing they put their
money into real estate speculation and
the financial speculation foreign
currency trade so the financialization
of London has helped de-industrialize
the country because it's enabled uh
Sterling to be supported by this huge
inflow of hot money this inflow of drug
dealing money and criminal money and a
tax evasion money all over the world
that is going to London instead of going
to Switzerland Lichtenstein or the
Caribbean
with the silent backing of the United
States
Britain's offshore Havens grew rapidly
and before long the offshore system
developed into the world's dominant
International Financial Market
few were aware how this Market
functioned
in 1986 economist John Christensen went
offshore to investigate
he applied for a position at the Jersey
office of one of the world's major
accounting firms but delight and touch I
was I was working in what's called
company and Trust Administration
straightforward optional stuff I went
off short specifically to work in that
area because that's where you're dealing
with the offshore companies the shell
companies the offshore trusts and you're
administering them that way I could I
could see from working inside a big
Global accounting firm exactly what the
clients were doing I had complete access
to all the client files and over the
course of my period of working with
Deloitte touche
I investigated over a hundred of their
clients offshore and this is what I
found
foreign
Traders some Market rigging some
avoiding disclosure of conflicts of
interest illicit arms trading illicit
political campaign donations contract
Kickbacks bribery fraudulent invoicing
trade mispricing and at the bottom tax
evasion
okay this is what the clients were doing
on the basis of a sample of the clients
that I looked at not a single client was
involved in what I would regard as
genuinely legitimate activity they were
all involved in some kind of tax dodging
or uh worse
I met with the car living used to be an
American Sonata
and he made a lot of inquiries into
private banking asking questions to the
bankers what do you think the percentage
is among your clients that are using
these companies for legitimate purposes
and the answer was I believe that 99.9
percent of my clients are using these
companies for illicit purposes
this is a reality this is American
Bankers telling what they are doing and
it's exactly the same thing with
UK bankers
helping their client to have accounts in
Panama or in Bermuda or in Cayman
Islands
[Music]
jurisdictions are heavily used for
fraudulent and gray area Financial
activities
areas where secrecy is not just
desirable but a necessity
legitimate Financial activity has no
need for the secrecy offshore Havens
provide nor a desire to pay the high
fees offshore Banks and law firms charge
today close to half of the world's
secrecy jurisdictions are British
dependencies
in public these jurisdictions claim they
are transparent and their financial
services sectors are engaged in
legitimate Financial activities
our economy is not based on secrecy it's
uh it's based on transparency it's based
on a sound regulatory environment it's
based on good governance and good
government uh with a British government
legal system that's what our financial
institutions are based on
well tonight we have a response from the
head of command Finance after a group of
U.S based anti-tax evasion activists
announced plans to travel to Cayman to
draw attention to what they feel is
corporate tax evasion Finance chairman
Mr Richard Cole says he's encouraging
the group to visit and says our
financial sector has nothing to hide
I would say if anybody wants to come to
Cayman to find out what what's coming
you know what we do here come on down we
Have No Secrets here
when I went to the Cayman Islands um
back in 2008 I think it was I called the
government spokesman he said okay we
have had an order from on high that
nobody is allowed to speak to you you
are off limits
in 2011 journalist Nicholas Jackson
released Treasure Islands a
groundbreaking book about the offshore
system
series of international media reports
says he would welcome a debate with
Cayman Finance chair Tony Travers Mr
Travers recently called Nicholas Jackson
an imbecile with the understanding of
enough of an 11 year old there are
always going to be the politics of Envy
now the politics of Envy are exacerbated
by uh imbeciles who don't actually
understand what's going on in the Cayman
Islands I don't know what he's talking
about and furthermore he doesn't know
what he's talking about
the Cayman Islands is the fifth largest
financial center in the world
it hosts 80 000 registered companies
over three quarters of the world's hedge
funds and 1.9 trillion dollars in
deposits
it has a population of sixty thousand
roughly equivalent to New York's
homeless population
a strange mixture of characters populate
the offshore world
British ex-public school boys
members of the world's intelligence
Services Global criminals assorted Lords
and Ladies and bankers Galore
[Music]
with so much at stake for so many
wealthy and Powerful individuals it may
come as no surprise that Britain's
offshore Havens have developed their own
curious mechanisms to prevent
information from leaking out
for many people who work offshore
and you don't like what they're doing
it's very hard indeed to dissent because
they will be attacked personally with a
degree of viciousness which is quite
extraordinary
most of the time the the instruments of
suppression are relatively sophisticated
you won't get promotional by doing this
or your family won't like it
it's not generally let's slam them in
prison that's far too crude we are
talking about very substantially you
know the establishment the British
establishment in in these cases the the
mechanisms are very very subtle sort of
ostracism is is one way of doing it
um these peculiar mechanisms for you
know if someone tries to to blow the
whistle you find all sorts of methods
that aren't the most you know just fire
them you give them far too much work to
do you steer them in a different
direction
foreign
who is intimately familiar with how
suppression Works offshore is former
Jersey senator and health Minister
Stuart sivre
in 2009 he leaked a report on a rogue
nurse suspected of killing patients at
Jersey's Hospital
it all came to a head during a state
Tuesday that the 10th of March Senator
Stewart sivre brought the sitting to a
standstill claiming Senator Jimmy
pershard had sworn at him and told him
to go and top himself
denied the claim saying I absolutely
refute that but less than a week later
he was forced to admit he'd lied Senator
pershard has now admitted that on
another occasion he did tell Senator
Stewart severe to go and do everyone a
favor and slit his wrists
I was uh arrested at my house one
morning by uh six plain clothes police
officers there were another two
specialist data search police officers
on hand and also another two police
officers in full body armor one of those
battering rams they're kind of using
drugs raids so 10 uh police officers
descended on me without a without a
search warrant the property was turned
over from top to bottom all of the
computers were seized and searched all
kinds of private constituency data was
stolen by the police
shortly after we began filming a police
officer exited the police station
as he hurried past he grinned at the
camera
the officer was on his way to test the
sirens on his motorbike which he did at
intervals throughout much of the
remainder of the interview
when it came to croskey
Stuart sivre was prosecuted under the
data Protection Law
when the authorities were Prosecuting me
I claimed that this was a legitimate
public interest disclosure defense and I
with an expert witness was able to
produce a set of reports that
effectively destroyed
[Music]
in reaction to this the magistrates
ruled that Stuart sivre's defense case
that he had leaked the report in the
public interest would no longer be
admissible
but continued to prosecute him all the
same without a defense case
over the past seven years Duart sivre
has been repeatedly taken to court and
imprisoned three times
he does not know when or if the
persecution will end nor does he know
when he will find himself Behind Bars
again
to look at Jersey from the outside it
looks like it's got a prosecution system
it looks like it's got a court and A
legislature but none of it's real it's a
potemkin village none of these systems
in Jersey meet the tests of being
objective
of being objective or actually
functioning properly the experience that
Stuart sivery had is you know he's
perhaps at the blunt of the scale you
know he was simply suppressed
and taken to court on trumped-up charges
[Music]
this is the kind of just kind of how
oppression happens in Jersey City all
kinds of little things get done to
harass people you know even they don't
often go to the kind of extremes they
did against me in terms of actually
arresting me and putting me in prison
but uh the authorities use all kinds of
other lesser little
methods to interfere with people kind of
sabotage things you know instruct people
make life difficult for people you know
if you annoy the establishments in
Jersey you won't get a job here you know
you know your children won't get decent
jobs now that's kind of how it works you
know
I went to church in March 2009 with with
Nick Jackson about 24 hours after we
arrived in Jersey we were there for
several days Nick said did you know that
have you noticed that we're being
followed ever since we arrived in at the
airport we've been followed he said
don't look now but we're being followed
now turns out it was quite correct we
were being followed
and I found that very disturbing very
disturbing indeed
they have a saying in Jersey
if you don't like it here there's always
a boat in the morning
Jersey Finance promotional literature
States Jersey represents an extension of
the city of London
it's where the city of London chooses to
do many of the activities which they
couldn't do in London itself
we're here to talk about this one
company called Applebee I just read what
they say on their website members of The
Firm Appleby have gone on not only to
political office but also in a number of
centers Bermuda Jersey the Isle of Man
and the Cayman Islands to senior
judicial office
so essentially they're boasting the fact
that their staff and their Partners have
a real interchange between the people
that are in power in these offshore
Financial Centers
the same lawyers and accountants who set
up and administer offshore trusts also
occupy senior political positions
in Britain's offshore world most
politicians are in business
they Lobby for business and promote
business interests
the draft refine and pass legislation
politicians sit on the boards of the
companies they are supposed to regulate
there is no place for dirty money in
Britain
indeed there should be no place for
Dirty Money anywhere the challenge I'm
laying down for every country today is
to root out the rot of corruption to
ensure transparency over what your own
companies are doing require transparency
for foreign companies in your country
too and work with us to spread this
approach to transparency around the
world
in public British politicians claim they
are cracking down on secrecy
jurisdictions and Corruption
but in practice they do the opposite
I talked to politicians in Brussels they
say that they've had more lobbyists
from
London
and including politicians come to them
to protect the city of London's
interests and they've had from every
other European member State combined
which gives you some ideality if extent
to which British politicians see
themselves as essentially lobbyists for
the city of London
there is being recognized by the
International Community earlier this
week the UK's Prime Minister David
Cameron told Parliament that the tax
Haven label placed on its crown
dependencies and overseas territories is
unfair
many British politicians have personal
and business ties with the city of
London and British secrecy jurisdictions
former British Prime Minister David
Cameron's father Ian Cameron was an
expert in offshore funds and was
involved in offshore trusts from the
1980s onwards
this Courthouse behind me here in
sinhalia we found this it's a document
called a grant of probate and it's
attached to the English will of none
other than Ian Cameron David Cameron's
father
[Applause]
Ian Cameron was certainly a wealthy man
in 2009 his personal Fortune was
estimated by researchers for the Sunday
Times rich list at 10 million pounds yet
when Ian Cameron died in 2010 his estate
was much smaller than might be expected
just 2.7 million pounds
in many cases it's the politicians and
their cronies and their families and so
on and the business people who sponsor
with the political parties who are using
these offshore Services themselves so so
they've got no personal interest in
closing it down if they wanted to close
it down they could do it tomorrow but
back to the matter is they don't want to
do it because they themselves are
complicit with the process
if you come from the same kind of
background you know the right people
then all the kind of legal niceties and
will will often fall away you can get
away with doing all sorts of things that
they wouldn't just let any old person
you know if you came knocking on the
door saying can you set up an offshore
company to do this they tell you to get
lost but
if you're part of the networks you can
you can do these kinds of things so
that's a very important part of the um
part of the whole system upper class
British Public School kind of
establishment that has been there since
you know for centuries
the British establishment an old boy's
network of privileged Elites had carved
out a lucrative Niche for themselves in
the offshore world after the demise of
Empire
they transformed themselves from
administrators of empire into Financial
handlers for the global Elite and
multinational corporations
as more money flowed offshore societies
around the globe began to feel the
impact of the offshore world
the reality is not what you believe that
your prime minister has the power to to
decide on the future of your country the
power is hidden here
we have country after country around the
world where the lack of financial
transparency about taxation about
ownership about corruption has
undermined the extent to which
governments deliver representative
policy making for their citizens you
know we have extreme cases like the The
Hiding of tax evasion by people in
finance Ministries in Greece in France
but we also have this system that in
general is geared towards Anonymous
Company ownership the anonymous
ownership of properties across London of
half of the land in Scotland you know do
we really think that any circumstances
in which governments work better in
which markets work better in which the
distribution of income and assets is
better when we allow so much to be
hidden who wants to not know who you're
doing business with who wants their
government to have people working for it
or to be led by people whose assets are
hidden whose Financial transactions are
conducted anonymously offshore you know
this is a bad direction for the world we
need the citizens to understand what is
happening that they are the ones who is
carrying the burden
and that some individuals having the
power are exonerating themselves
Ordinary People are paying taxes
rich people are not so this is
inequality
and it is leading up to populism because
it shows so clearly that the people
today leading the world are not able to
take care of the interest of Ordinary
People
back in the 60s and 70s you know
activation or pushing back against
taxation it was kind of seen as
anti-establishment so you know the
Rolling Stones and Phil Collins all
these people kind of going offshore
going away
it was seen as a sort of rebellious
thing to do and if you fast forward to
the present day
now that is the establishment the
offshore system is the establishment
today offshore is the way Elites and
multinational corporations conduct their
affairs
tax evasion is the way business is done
this kind of sophisticated cheating
requires a huge infrastructure we like
to talk about the Pinstripe
infrastructure of Highly Educated people
who think it is their right to help
others to cheat societies
we have a new mafia in town it does not
actually shoot people does not put
bullets in their kneecaps but this trade
is just as deadly it deprives people of
opportunities to have health care
education security Justice and
essentially a fulfilling life
accountants form the backbone of the
offshore system
they administer the structures that
allow individuals and corporations to
shift their money offshore and evade
taxes
there are about 2.5 million
professionally qualified accountants on
this planet about 330 000 are in the UK
well-known people well-dressed well-fed
highly paid are sitting in City Center
offices and they are paid to dream up
tax avoidance schemes for individuals
and for corporations
we can all elect a government which says
vote for us we will give you better
health care better education
better security and next day account and
say sorry about that folks you elected
this government but we actually got a
tax avoidance scheme and the Amazons and
the Googles and microsofts won't be
paying any taxes in your jurisdiction
too bad you voted for it but actually
you're going to get something else so
it's a crazy world that part of the
business model at Big accountancy firms
is how to deny public the services by
erosion
of tax revenues and these firms are then
rewarded with government-funded
contracts and the same firms are then
advising uh local governments and the
central governments and the same firms
then report on the company account and
tell us all as well when I argue this
with a pricewaterhouse partner and a
face-to-face debate he said Professor
sikar you never give us credit for
anything we generate millions of dollars
of revenues
and we have lots and lots of satisfied
clients what is your problem
and my response is very simple that's
the language of drug pushers and pimps
[Music]
in Britain a new breed of civil servant
was rising to the top
one such civil servant was Dave Hartnett
Who Rose to the top of hmrc the UK tax
Authority
Dave Hartnett had a new way of
collecting tax
deals would be negotiated on an
individual basis behind closed doors
in the case of the largest clients Dave
Hartnett frequently led the negotiations
himself
British Telecom was one of the first
companies through the program and
received a refund of over 1 billion
pounds
BT's chief executive Ben fervan wrote
earnings per share up 14 and nice to
know that we have a 1 billion pound
credit from the taxman
Dave Hartnett claimed this approach was
more efficient
litigation in the courts is really
phenomenally expensive in this day and
age all over the world
and I think it's to be avoided where
possible
and the artists to persuade people to
pay by strength of argument and the like
[Music]
after protests erupted in 2011
the treasury select committee questions
Dave Hartnett
Dave Hartnett claimed he could not give
any information due to taxpayer
confidentiality
statue prevents you from disclosing
information to Parliament
all my advice Mr Barclay so far has been
that I am prevented my colleagues have
prevented by the act and by the decision
of the commissions
Dave Horton had failed to mention that
the legal advice he had received stated
that the disclosure of information was
at the discretion of the head of hmrc
the head of hmrc was Dave Hartnett
himself
just like the mafia has penetrated the
state accountancy firms have also
penetrated the state at the head of
anti-avoidance in the UK
tax Authority is from one of these firms
the newly appointed chairman of Her
Majesty's revenue and Customs which is a
tax Authority is a partner from KPMG
their Partners have penetrated the state
they are running the treasury
Britain's Financial Services industry
had penetrated the state
and began to shape its laws for its own
benefit
the degree of catch political capture by
the city of London by the big Banks and
the big law firms is so enormous that
the politicians have effectively become
their spokespersons
with the government unwilling to act in
the interest of the public
a group of protesters confronted Dave
Hartnett at a private event in Oxford
is the lifetime achievements award and
services it's a corporate tax planning
thank you
[Applause]
great friends in the industry a great
friend to many of us over the years and
you know really we just can't thank you
enough for what he's done obviously it
was a Vodafone
um you know it saved us billions off our
tax bill and our friends at Goldman
Sachs as well we've also saved us
Millions 20 25 million
[Music]
services and Intruders and I know you've
had problems
[Music]
you will depart immediately before we
set the dogs on you
[Music]
okay
you are trespassing skunk
[Music]
after his retirement Dave Hartnett moved
to the private sector one of his
positions was at accountancy firm
Deloitte where he advises foreign
governments on corporate taxation
Dave Hartnett is a companion of the
order of the bath
an honor bestowed on him by the British
monarch
we have former our ministers acting as
advisors to accountancy firms
accountancy firms provide jobs and
consultancies for potential ministers to
my mind really it's an indication of
corrupt structures people are buying and
selling influences when in my former
Minister works for an accountancy firm
is not providing any accounting
knowledge is opening political
opportunities home and abroad that is
what they are doing I hope by now you'll
share My Views that I don't trust most
Bankers I don't trust most lawyers I
don't trust most accounting firms I
actually think they're engaged in the
conspiracy against public interest
in Britain secrecy and complexity in
finance and government helped to obscure
corruption in public office
Financial structures are often so
complex that even after they are
publicly revealed they are not widely
recognized for what they are
an example of this is PFI
the private Finance initiative PFI is
private Finance initiative it is a way
of funding public infrastructure things
like hospitals schools roads and bridges
but financing them via the private
sector rather than the Historical Method
which is via central government over a
period of 30 or 40 years the amounts of
kind of repayment costs will be sort of
three or four times higher overall than
if you borrow it from central government
in the first place so it's basically a
joint accounting scheme
once the PFI policy has been set up you
find that the big four accountancy firms
were actually paid members of Staff
within the treasury Department who were
then actually going around and selling
and Advising upon the implementate
implementation of PFI contracts by
public authorities
effectively saying come to us and we
will show you how to derive the most
benefit from it in other words how to
perhaps exploit the legislation even the
offices
of the state tax Authority are now own
offshore hmrc which is the the tax
collector here in the UK the offices are
owned in Bermuda
by a company called make these steps
it's quite incredible
the company that owns the PFI contract
to run hmrc's head office
borrowed money from offshore investors
at 15 interest
because the interest was so high the
company was losing money
therefore it did not pay tax
in 2011 hmrc could not prove that any
PFI company was paying any tax in the UK
I think we'd have a serious conversation
about the the role of government in this
whole debacle and how much our
government has been penetrated by big
Banks and accountancy firms and
ultimately in who's interested operates
the reason we were protesting outside
the Africa PPP conference is that we
wanted to make sure that citizens back
in Africa should hear about the fact
that such policies have been a complete
failure here in the UK we know that
these products are not being marketed to
African countries in their own best
interests their only motivation is to
spread the reach of financial services
into new markets it's all being promoted
in the interest of the city of London
what you're seeing is basically a second
form of colonialization you've had
initially occupation resource extraction
um you know and through that process you
know countries like Britain which have
had a large offshore Empire have
developed significant networks and there
are those networks being used to promote
and exploit Financial Services
foreign
[Music]
was the beating Financial heart of the
British Empire
as Britain's Empire declined the city
transformed itself from a hub operating
the financial Machinery of Empire
into a Global Financial Center
former insignificant outposts of Empire
became the basis for a spider's web of
offshore secrecy jurisdictions that
captured wealth from across the globe
and funneled it to the city of London
foreign
of international finance is conducted on
British territory
almost half of the world's secrecy
jurisdictions are under British
protection
up to half of all offshore wealth may be
hidden in Britain's offshore Havens
[Music]
Financial Services is how Britain's
Elites make their money
and it is also where former government
ministers senior civil servants and
retired Spooks from MI5 and MI6 receive
lucrative Consulting positions after
their time in public service
together they have transformed Britain
and its dependencies into the world's
largest tax Haven harming development
throughout the world and turning Britain
itself into a country that serves above
all the interests of its Elites
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]